in 1964 the American government funded
2/3 of all R&D in America 2/3 if you
were a Midwest company wanting to do
research you wrote a grant to the
Commerce Department absolutely insane
and since 1964 this has now gone down
and today the American government like
oecd governments everywhere the American
government funds only 20% of American
R&D and 10 and half of that is defense
so only 10% of American Civil R&D is
funded by the state in that time there
therefore has been across the oecd a
fall in the Public Funding of R&D I
could give you the data but let me just
say that but the consequence has been a
growth in the private funding
threefold for every dollar the P the
public sector has withdrawn from the
funding of research the private sector
has put in three extra dollars more than
compensate now AR Arie Buji and
filipetti say admit that this is
crowding out they don't pretend it's not
crowding out they claim it's a bad thing
we could go into that that they are of
course wrong but the reason is why now
is a good thing because it's where that
techn industry is where technology comes
from what is the mechanism of crowding
out the mechanism is s scientific
quality if the government creates
University
that all the best scientists go to and
the best scientists go to universities I
mean we're all used to now Silicon
Valley and that sort of thing we all
understand that good scientists can
create companies and do nonetheless the
majority of scientists are like Jane
Austin they're looking for fame they go
to
universities if you take the best
scientists out of the market and put
them into universities you leave
industry with the not so good scientists
and therefore industry doesn't get a
return on its investment
and therefore it looks for other ways of
making money marketing or something and
so the government funding of research
which others not me I mean I have also
shown it but the point is others have
shown creates crowding out 3 to one it's
a very serious crowding out takes the
best scientists out of industry and
therefore damages rates of economic
growth now we are
told that governments have to fund
science because the market
disincentivizes companies from doing
science so the myth that we are told by
the economists is if I do science I'll
be disincentivized because my discovery
which costs me a lot of money to make
Tony will take for nothing in his
company and therefore for him the
discovery is free for me it costs a lot
of money therefore he will outperform me
I will go bust and he'll make all the
profit that is the story The Economist
tell and it is a story based on an utter
myth that assumes that knowledge is
what's called EXP explicit but actually
knowledge is tacit there's no way that I
say making iPhones I'm going to be
competed with except by other companies
making mobile phones and they are uh
capable of copying my research only by
the research they themselves have done
over the previous 20 30 years which has
given the expertise to copy my research
and vice versa so the costs of copying
you can show are actually 10000 % on
average the marginal costs are less than
100% but the average or the total cost
is 100% it costs as much to copy on
average as it does to innovate so it's
just a myth that the market doesn't
reward science actually the company that
says that uh it's not going to fund
science because it's worried about its
discoveries being copied by other people
should be told fine don't do science and
see how long it takes you before you go
bankrupt not very long so to summarize
the American government didn't fund
science here Tony and I agreed on the
facts until the second world war and
particularly Sputnik when the Americans
suddenly thought oh my Heavens we're
going to be overtaken by the Russians
that really was the belief and what is
interesting is what the American
government funded in 1957 because it's
exactly as Tony says NASA and arper now
known as Dara the American government
recognized that the linear model the
National Science Foundation model had
failed the Russians were in space and so
they went back to the traditional model
of mission science when you have a
particular Mission governments can
actually deliver on that mission
governments can actually deliver on atom
bombs they can deliver on operation warp
speed give a government a mission and it
can succeed the myth the dangerous myth
is that the government funding of pure
science through the linear model is
itself a stimul to economic growth
someone whom Tony and I both know wrote
in the magazine that Tony once edited
new Atlantis that the linear model is a
lie and it is it's a lie it's been
promoted heavily by governments it's
promoted by because they want the
glory when the human genome was was
sequenced in the year 2000 who announced
it to the world Bill Clinton the great
patron of science so governments want to
fund science industry wants to fund
science because it thinks wrongly it's
getting money back for its taxes it
thinks it's getting a subsidy scientists
want government to fund science because
they don't want to work for industry
they want to work in a peer-reviewed
system so they basically fund themselves
according to the science they want to do
and the general public believes somehow
that governments should fund science
because we all want to see programs on
Netflix about penguins and
things what has actually happened is
that that model has failed the
government knows it's failed there's
been this fantastic collapse in the
government funding of research and
development and the consequence has only
been an accelerated rate of economic
growth thank you very
much